okay next game let's play d4 this time
can I get a Queens gambit and let's see
what line is coming up with okay we
gotta exchange variation always pleasant
to play aha the only h6 let's see if I
can make any use some of the smooth it's
not supposed to be that great of course
it just creates a weakness here so I try
to guess along and and play g-form later
okay let's try the video g4 I think it
needs to be a bit careful now maybe with
the bishop h7 and white squares somewhat
weak here
yeah it's not so easy to suggest
something for black okay just a form and
form I don't think I have anything
directly here okay interesting question
now d takes what I think I prefer this
one open up the F file and then try
playing quickly h 45 yeah this is a
temporary block here yeah maybe I should
try to get the knight to f3 but he also
has got Knight to g5 so it's not so easy
to to break this okay first the Queen
over here
not so not so sure how to proceed maybe
if night e 2 g-3 f5 could be a plan yeah
maybe this is interesting okay maybe you
will try a c5 at some point so I spent
one move to get the King um from c.c
file rookie 7sm and i know runs into my
my night f5 idea of course you can play
g602 to stop this
I could also just play you fall at some
point the idea if it takes Queen takes
you for having an iron-on on h7
difficult of course why this is very
good here but so not not an automatic
win or something least take some time I
also might never get one first okay he's
not threatening anything I think so
maybe look everyone first when it moved
like f6 I think I can always play Knight
a form and then I g6 and the queen is
almost wrapped okay
yeah i think i need to provoke g6 don't
think you can allow me to to get in here
be hard to believe
and after g6 tried to regroup maybe back
to f4 and threaten to take on g6 down
after g6 he can never play f6 oh yeah
should be wrapped up any counter play
yeah this looks looks pretty nice right
he's got no obvious moves okay
retreating yeah okay but okay let's just
play here and open up the file of course
he can try to block even fall didn't
expect that but this is promised GG good
point if you adjust the dead position
okay what now get form forget for I
think
okay now the only movie he actually has
all the greenness to g5 of the edge for
threatened should be to just picking up
the Queen okay he gave himself as ground
he ate but G file is also not too bad
okay so still fairly close position how
to make progress ache I could I could
bring the bishop to to h5 of course yeah
maybe tried that you see somehow
threatening g5 know maybe maybe he is
sure let's play this first getting
maximum pressure on on the G file not
try to switch the bishop over ok no
Bishop f7 should timeline window g7
cornea at least or one exchange or
something ok of course IAM cannot escape
with a walk ok and now queen age six
sisters check made you know very closely
knit stack resigned yeah i could have
played knowledge talking about the kids
completely lost of course yeah yeah this
was just um just a bad opening I think
it's important to note that the h6 move
here is some is really difficult for
black to handle because um it just gives
me automatic gun points of a tech here
with G for later so it really is
advisable to switch to a long castling
set up here one negative point of h6 is
also that he can bring the night to to
f8 as that's as usual here but he cannot
play on ig6 for instance or pawn to g6
which are all a normal moves on because
of h6 is not possible and I just go for
g4 and if he doesn't react somehow I
just push h4 g5 and so on and it's an
easier tech it's um it's really a long
time until black will get something
decent going against my kingdom because
I'm also much quicker here in
development so h6 is really serious in
an accuracy or at least if not if not
downright mistaken ok next game